we did catch up with Robert DeNiro and
Jane Rosenthal the two co-founders of
the Tribeca Film Festival and I began by
asking them about a controversial film
that looks at vaccines and vaccinations
and autism and I asked them about why
they decided to remove it from the
festival I wanted to put it in I had
seen it I I don't know enough but I know
bit and what I was hearing and it made a
valid entry for me in a certain way and
I never get involved in entries at all
and most I do is somebody asked and I
say there's the the people you go see
Jane they she steers it to where they
decide and what film is they totally out
of it I felt that this was something
that people should at least see and
there was a strong reaction from people
who I didn't expect to have such a
strong reaction the way I've been told
but I felt that we all felt that let me
I don't want to get the the festival in
some kind of controversy that would be a
Miss a Miss perception about it so I
said let's just pull it it got attention
oddly enough and there are things that I
don't necessarily I don't know enough
about but I'm curious about but it makes
me want to know and there's also another
movie called trace amount that I saw
which I found very interesting you know
maybe it's not all true but there's
something there and I asked questions
nothing wrong with having discussion
about it so we're not we're the
festival's known for our documentaries
and clearly now we're also known for a
documentary that we didn't take but
where we have a very strong documentary
filmmakers and that's what the festival
is known for and regrets and having it
in the first place
included in the lineup no no we we
pulled it and that's okay they were in
it one of the biggest one of the biggest
lessons of any kind of leadership is to
admit when you've made a mistake or you
see things differently and and change
the course and I think at this point
everybody's happy I feel like you guys
have really changed the course of what
happened down
after 9/11 you just look around what's
going on right now 15 years I feel like
you've multiplied in terms of your
offerings social media technology do you
feel like that there's a point where the
festival could get too big do you want
to keep it a certain size you definitely
want to keep it as certain size as a
matter of fact which we probably
screened less movies
than we have in years past I forget the
exact number of movies were screening
but we're we screen less movies but we
we're competing for things for people's
attention here here in New York and we
have amazing panel discussions where do
it new this year is our Tribeca TuneIn
technology and social media you continue
to embrace and I know you've done it
with vine films you had a competition
and you're doing things with snapchat
this year what role do you feel like
media social media technology should
play in the festival yeah you can have
to you know I love 11 and I love virtual
reality I love any kind of new form of
telling stories so it is and our whole
our whole festival team feels that way
Jane earlier this year you stepped down
as CEO why name Andrew and what do you
hope he does with the enterprise I've
done an awful lot of the festival so in
order for me to continue doing what I
love to do and we'll be running the
day-to-day and he's a great partner and
it's really exciting to be able to work
with him Madoff you I know I asked every
year what did you get out of play Madoff
we worked with Vanna and Rica's who
wrote there was an obligor rific and
Barry Levinson of the Sun did you like
him by the end may know I I don't know
you know it's it's such a complicated
character he's such a complicated that I
don't pretend to know or understand or
anything I just tried what I felt was
what it was that's all all right so
obviously yeah the cofounders of the
Tribeca Film Festival they co-founded it
15 years ago Jane Rosenthal and of
course actor Robert De Niro and talking
about a variety of topics and he did
spend a lot of time
talking about that that documentary
quarry that did get killed from the
festival he has an autistic child so
this is something kind of near and dear
but it's interesting and this has become
a festival they have all kinds of films
covering so many things there's a
there's a documentary about Bill Ackman
and its crusade against Herbalife so
it's absolutely there's a lot of
different things and they do embrace um
technology it's also the 40th
anniversary of taxi driver so they've
got a great panel on that lots of
interesting stuff going on yeah though
the comments about leadership as brief
as those comments were we're very
powerful and speak to leaders of any
kind of Enterprise where there's
business or a film does Jane Rosenthal
so as a present certainly big time in
the movie industry